[Music]
so my optimism is rooted in the fact
that for over almost 200 years every
year has gotten a little bit better when
we look at the scientific evidence and
that while it's possible that next year
everything could change everything could
collapse and fall to the ground
statistically probabilistically it won't
it will continue because 200 years is
gone and next year it probably will
continue but if you look at the kind of
current political regime around the
world and the factors of of pressures
environmental pressures the pressures of
distraction that we have from the new
media then I think you have to resort to
hope in the long term optimists decide
the future it's the optimist who create
all the things are gonna be most
important in our lives because it was
optimists who built and invented all the
things that are now important in our
current lives and I think people behave
better when they're optimistic there's
absolutely a need to be critical and
doubtful and skeptical and even
pessimistic just like if you have a car
you have to have brakes you can't have a
car no matter where it is without brakes
but it's the engine the optimistic
engine that keeps going and going and
refuses to stop and it's only concerned
about going forward that really drives a
car but you certainly need brakes to
steer it and I think if you have only
brakes you don't go anywhere and I think
what we have right now is we have an
imbalance between pessimism and optimism
and we really need a lot more optimism
about the future in order to have that
engine keep going and I think that one
of the reasons why we maybe have an
imbalance right now is because we have
been burned so often by the promises of
the optimists
about how technology is going to bring
us a kind of utopia and I think nobody
believes in utopia anymore I certainly
don't
but dystopia is actually not any better
and that's actually the only vision that
we have of the future which is really
sort of made by Hollywood and some
science fiction which is of a dystopia
that collapses and I think that while we
can't believe in a utopia I think a
better vision of the future is proto Pia
this idea that we have incremental
progress that were working in creeping
very very steadily but slowly towards
betterment so every year is a little
tiny better than the year before
not much but a little tiny better and
that kind of incremental progress is
really only visible when you turn around
and look back behind you because a half
or even a 1% difference is really
something we can't see every year and
it's not gonna be seen in the news if
you look at the news and news is about
outliers about unusual things it's not
about the slow evidence of progress
which is not seen in the news so if you
want to see what's really happening the
world you can't look at the news you
have to look at the scientific evidence
which is going to register a very small
Delta that is really not visible unless
you turn around and look behind you and
then you can see oh 20 years this is
real and so that sense of proto PIA of a
small incremental creep towards
betterment that next year will be a
little tiny better than this year is
really the best that we have but it's a
very powerful thing because that's what
civilization is civilization is not
monumental heroic enterprise it's a
small creep of 1% betterment through
centuries and I think if we believe that
progress is real then we can actually
behave better if we believe that
progress is real we can still dream
about making these new things
because we know that even though the new
technologies are going to introduce as
many new problems as a solve and that
most of the problems we'll have in the
future will come from new technology we
will still go forward and make invent
those new things even though they will
create new problems because those new
problems themselves will birth new
solutions which will have new problems
but that circle and cycle keeps going
around around and there's a 1% net gain
for each revolution and that's what we
get out of this
[Music]